SIMON PAMPENA: I want to take
a little bit of a departure
from looking at specific numbers
and ask the question,
how do you measure numbers?
This was one of the most
challenging things I came
across studying maths at uni,
was this notion of how to
measure, mathematically
measure.
So this is what I'm
going to do.
I'm going to show you the
real number line.
Yeah, you're familiar
with that right?
So think about this.
This is the real number line.
It's there in your head.
So here's my question.
What's the distance
between 3 and 4?
What's the measure?
How long is that section?
BRADY HARAN: 1.
SIMON PAMPENA: 1.
How did you get that?
BRADY HARAN: Because I know the
number that I need to add
to 3 to get to 4 is 1.
SIMON PAMPENA: OK,
that's good.
So you know the number.
So you know the answer,
basically, you're saying?
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
SIMON PAMPENA: OK,
well, imagine you
didn't know the answer.
So imagine this is the first
time you've ever tried to
measure the distance
between 3 and 4.
What would you do?
BRADY HARAN: I'd make a piece
of wood the distance
between 0 and 1.
And then I would take it to 3
and 4 and see how many of them
do I have to put on there.
SIMON PAMPENA: OK,
that's good.
That's good.
I like that.
It's actually good that you
brought in reality.
Because that's going
to really bite you.
It's going to really bite you.
But that's cool.
That's cool.
I like the fact you said that.
So basically you said, OK, well,
I'm going to look at a
bit of a number line which
I know what the length is
because it starts at 0.
And you're going to go
and drag it over
until you measure it.
But another way you could do
it is you could say, this
number, take that number.
So you're comfortable
with that.
You know that that distance
there is 4 take 3.
Now this is what's
called naive.
And that's not a putdown.
It's naive.
It's a naive way of
measuring numbers.
I'm hopefully going to take you
down the rabbit hole now.
3.5 is a point right there.
I'm going to put a little
kind of, little bit of
choke wire around it.
3.5 is a point.
Do you agree that it exists?
3 and 1/2?
BRADY HARAN: I'm happy
with that.
SIMON PAMPENA: You're
happy with that, OK.
What's the length
of 3 and 1/2?
BRADY HARAN: What's
the length of it?
Well, to give you a length,
I need a start
point and an end point.
SIMON PAMPENA: No, I'm just
talking about the point, just
the point, one point.
So what's the length
of a point?
BRADY HARAN: Points
don't have length.
SIMON PAMPENA: What's another
way of saying that?
3.5 take 3.5 is 0.
We use exactly the same logic
that we used here for the
segment of line.
We're going to use the same
logic for the point.
Now, this sounds like I'm being
trivial, maybe even annoying.
But I am getting somewhere.
I'm making a point
about points.
Because what now is the
length of 3 to 4 if we
remove the point 3.5?
What is the length of
that line segment?
BRADY HARAN: The length
is still 1.
SIMON PAMPENA: Why?
BRADY HARAN: Because the thing
you removed took up no space.
SIMON PAMPENA: That's right.
So this idea is that we've got
a line segment, 3 to 4, which
is made up of a continuous
set of points.
There's only points
between 3 and 4.
But if we remove 3.5, we
haven't changed it.
We haven't changed it at all.
And part of the reason behind
that is because the real
number line has this property
that there is no next number.
What's the number after 3.5?
BRADY HARAN: 3.50000000000000--
SIMON PAMPENA: Yeah, exactly.
But you're not even saying
that correctly.
Because the way that we describe
numbers doesn't
contain the awesomeness of
what's going on here.
Why is this a problem?
Because we are using stuff
that we haven't proved.
We're using naive notions
of measure.
That's why that's a problem.
We're making assumptions.
This almost broke maths where
I'm going with this.
It almost broke maths.